I had mike tomlin on NFL Network on that
Saturday finishing up with the draft the
steals were pretty much already all the
hay was in the barn after Zach Gentry
they tied in from Michigan made it to
players that they chose in the draft
from my alma mater and this happened
coach what about University of Michigan
players makes the other institutions of
higher learning and also football
programs that made you choose two of
them in this year's draft Richie just
get that feeling that you walk in the
Schembechler hall man here in the
college football setting it and then you
see the big house and in the back it
just lets you know you count in the
right place and I realize I'm giving you
exactly what it is you want right now
there you go coach always you know we
were we've always been like this fingers
crossed
joining me right now is the man that the
steel has moved up ten spots in the
first round to select last time they did
that was to take joy Polamalu when the
draft
he's Devin Bush Pittsburgh Steeler how
are you doing I'm good how you doing did
you know Coach felt about walking into
Schembechler Hall that way yeah I could
relate and I understand everything he
had I walk in to send back definitely so
it just it just seems to me this is a
perfect fit Devin just from the outside
I'm wondering how you feel so far first
couple weeks in your first training camp
oh yeah I'm feeling good you know my
house is good mix is good plans that
have a fun well just in terms of good
yeah in terms of a fit just the scheme
the Steelers you it just feels like the
fit and again I'm wondering how you feel
oh yeah I mean I'm playing football man
and I think that that's what my biggest
fit comes in I'm desire on the team I
get to compete and I get to go out there
every day and do what I love so how this
is perfectly right now what what has
Tomlin told you face to face Devin was
like hey you know you've been playing
football your whole life obviously this
is not due to you so you know bu and
what four Steelers friends you may not
be aware what what is being you mean if
you know me who your fan be you would
know
for those who don't know ma'am I'm just
a guy a lot of play football man just
energetic bring energy passion big
splash plays and a lot of fly around and
have fun
Devin Bush Steelers rookie linebacker
here on the Rich Eisen show is it true
draft night you got a text from Ryan
shazier Devin I got a couple of ticks oh
yeah but yeah he definitely was one who
checks me congratulating me and just
letting me know you know me support me
to India deputy so did that surprise you
looking down at your phone seeing that I
was crazy it was really just to have you
know that type of guy reach out to you
and you know that he's in your corner
and and what has he been saying to you
since have you have you kept in touch
you say I trying to camp with us on a
daily he's out there on the field when
you're doing i individual or we don't
achieve competitions and you know he's
just you know throw me our tips and
their advice you know whether it's
football or not you know he's always we
always stay in constant contact and you
know we just talk so give me a piece of
advice that he's given you that you've
taken a hard definite bullshittin here
uh just being a good players like well
if you want to play a long time as leads
it's dedicate yourself to be a great do
all the things necessary to be great you
know by the time you look up and sure
you'll be in years eight nine and Tom
Slava so what what have you seen so far
in your training camp that you see you
need to work on so far um just a mental
part obviously playing with you come
with these group of guys you know
everybody's physically gifted and
everybody could do it physically and uh
I think the mental part is where I need
to you know get the upper hand and study
film more and uh be able just to
understand more the defense and more of
the offense and I have a child attackers
so who on the team veteran is thrown
their arm around you Devin and tried to
show you some ropes it's a couple arm
Dez Williams Marc banner stays here cam
Haywood bud Dupree you know
guys you know they they they help me out
tremendously with any and everything any
advice you know they stand by my side
and you're probably hearing how many
people are putting a lot of hopes in you
the defense has been you know quite
frankly missing your type of speed your
type of ability since Ryan shazier left
the field I wonder how you shoulder that
burden Devin Bush in Pittsburgh I
already think about it a lot as much
people think I'm supposed to or should
be kind of just approach it as you know
I'm Devin Bush and I said you have to be
to be they injure asked me to to come in
and be righteous here and you know
that's that's not my hopes and my
hosting to come in and be Douglas and
now that's that's my biggest my biggest
drive is to let everybody know about Who
I am and your dad won the Superbowl or
with the Rams what what is he passed
along to you Devin everything I know
about football about life you know about
being a professional you know he's he's
the reason I am Who I am today and um
and big big big house of the house
so let's just say you're warming up
before a game against the Browns Ravens
let's just throw the Ravens out there
and do you they walk arm-in-arm across
the field name is the same result
really though so that Ravens that Ravens
logo gets torn up is that what happens I
rave a little have a big scratch how
much have you kept in touch with the
alma mater already or I just off the
phone with a couple of my teammates last
night I talked to two I'm seeing how it
is and obviously it's just a tough camp
I'm missing him yes that's football
heaven over there okay Rob and I I just
started doing good so looking for them
have a good seat all right tell me Devin
did tell me in the rest of the Wolverine
faithful because we're seeing another
top-ten preseason poll etc and so on and
so forth I mean
what can you what can you tell me about
what you're hearing about Michigan's
team I heard I heard uh the office is
pretty good that's one thing I've heard
the defense is also really good so uh I
think it's all about putting it together
that's why I'm here
so uh this is what the train to campus
board is to put it all together as one
complete unit and go out there and do
what they do
no way so you know you're closer to Ohio
than ever before they're in western
Pennsylvania Devon I mean are you
running into a lot of flack at all or no
as you're in Penn State Colin you're
you're not you're you know I've seen a
couple of a couple bucks obviously I
mean I stand in touch with one city I
know that it's really as amazing then
and then I played behind cam Hayworth so
that's another one I kind of gotta face
it here in the tell me about it I
thought I try to stay away I just came
back from Canton Ohio Devin I mean what
do you think every single minute I walk
around yeah I know
all right so before I let you go Devin
what is your goal for for the first year
gimme I do you write these things down
at all
I kind of keep them in the back of my
head so put it in your head out your
mouth gage what do you got my goals for
the season is to come in you know play
and come in play win okay Devin Busch
you take care of yourself we'll chat
soon okay all right thank you that's
Devin Busch Steelers linebacker man a
few words for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app